قتل مليون عراقي
وتسبب بقتل وإصابة مئات الآلاف من جنوده،
وخسرت بلاده مئات مليارات الدولارات في عهده،
لقد كنت تكذب علينا، وعليك أن تعتذر،
جملة قالها جندي أمريكي لرئيسه السابق جورج بوش الإبن،
يقابلها رشق بالأحذية
من صحفي عراقي لبوش الإبن أيضا
، الجنود يتساءلون عن السبب،
وبوش لا يستطيع الإجابة.،،
فما الذي قاله الجنود القدامى لبوش الإبن؟
وما هي ردت فعل بوش بعد كل هذا؟...
قبل ذلك لا تنسى الإعجاب بالفيديو والاشتراك بالقناة
وتفعيل الجرس لنستمر بالمزيد إن شاء الله، ،
في أحد مؤتمراته في ولاية كاليفورنيا،
كان بوش يتحدث عن ولايته السابقة في الحكم،،،
قاطعه أحد جنوده السابقون،،
وقال...
• متى ستقدم على الاعتذار عن حرب العراق؟
• متى ستعتذر عن موت ملايين العراقيين؟
• كنت تكذب بشأن وجود أسلحة دمار شامل في العراق.
• لقد كذبت بشأن علاقة العراق بهجمات الحادي عشر من سبتمبر/ أيلول 2001.
• كنت كاذبا عندما زعمت أن العراق يمثل تهديدا لنا.
وانتقد الجندي الأمريكي السابق الرئيس الأسبق جورج بوش الابن،
مؤكدا أن بوش أرسله إلى العراق عام 2003،
مضيفا: "رأيت مقتل أصدقائي بسببك أنت".
وتابع: "أنت قتلت الناس... أنت تكذب... أنت تحتاج إلى الاعتذار".
وبينما كان صوت الجندي يزاد حدة، أخذه الجنود إلى خارج القاعة،
جندي آخر يقول عندما وقف بوش عند برجي التجارة
بعد أحداث ١١ سبتمبر متعهدا بملاحقة المتورطين،
لبى هذا الجندي ويدعى توماس يونغ النداء،
فأرسلوه إلى العراق بدلا عن أفغانستان،
وفي اليوم الخامس له تعرض لإصابة في عموده الفقري،
وأصيب بالشلل، وعلى كرسيه المتحرك
ظل يخرج في الحملات المناوئة لنظام بوش، لكن معاناته وعيشه على المغذيات،
جعلته يحاول الانتحار في العديد من المرات،
كانت زوجته تحاول مساعدته على الانتحار
ولكن القانون يمنعها من ذلك،
فوجهت كل الاتهامات نحو بوش وطالبت بمحاكمته،
أما المستشار الألماني السابق جيرهارد شرودر،
فقد اتهم بوش بالكذب وتزوير الحقائق،
فيما يخص موقف ألمانيا من الحرب،
جورج بوش الابن نفسه، يرد على الأسئلة ويقول،
أنه لم يكن هناك أسلحة دمار شامل في العراق،
ولكن كان بإمكانهم تصنيعها،
لكن من سيبرر له ملايين الضحايا،
من العراقيين ومن الجنود الذين ذهب بهم للعراق،
وماذا عن مليارات الدولارات؟
فلماذا لا تتم محاكمته على كل جرائمه تلك،
خوف بوش وحلفاؤه من صدام جعلهم يرتكبون جرائم بشعة في العراق،
فأين المتشدقون بحقوق الإنسان،
وأين هي العدالة التي يتحدث عنها الغرب؟...
ومتى يجد الغرب من يردعهم عن أفعالهم الدنيئة،،،،
لطفا وليس أمرا.. ادعمونا باللايك والاشتراك وتفعيل الجرس لنستمر بالمزيد إن شاء الله